hey Vsauce Michael here next to a giant
bird which can only mean one thing I'm
in London where even the villas say god
save the queen it's a cushion my god
all right look I've got a bird trying to
tell me what to say that's right in
England this is a bird and this is a
bird of course I called her hazel but
I've got a little piece of knowledge for
you hazel it's a new word and the word
is dog is that something you eat no it's
things you do online now guys i'ma beat
beasts recommended music covering an
awesome sight with a mood pad mouse over
the pad to choose your current or
desired mood and it immediately changes
you can even focus on a decade or genre
within your mood but if you want
complete control upload your own
favorite song to pixel white like you'll
occasion the game lasts as long as the
song you upload and the songs equalizer
bars become the playing space dis choir
91 brought up a list of sites where you
can waste time like a professional while
I was there I found no calm when
something terrible happens go there and
push the button
[Applause]
I also discovered oooo iiiii comm the
title makes more sense after you go
there but if you want the cast
Alex's computer ception play a game
where you're on a computer or coach here
recommends a game with state of the art
ASCII graphics you're a roflcopter
dropping WTF bombs on guys wearing
Lawler skates to fancy will play this
even simpler game programmed to happen
inside your URL bar use the arrow keys
to move the o to lasso a z' and press
the spacebar to kill as many as possible
in 30 seconds
pointless sites is another good
collection of places while I was there I
found 1 billion mazes a site that
literally has 1 billion mazes if you
solved one maze every single second it
would take you more than 31 years to
finish them all speaking of long times
here's a YouTube video of a guy counting
to a hundred thousand and yeah that says
74 hours 41 42 43 44 45 but to feel
really sad play platformer and learn a
life lesson videos do you want more well
this one is a really sweet playlist
containing the first hour of MTV as it
originally aired with the original
commercials and lately I've been working
with greg from dr. coolsex and getting
into his WTF series each week we learn a
little bit more about what happened or
what's happening you be the judge and if
you're in London I hope to see you it's
summer in the city tomorrow and as
always thanks for watching